helps on my name is Samuel leaves this
week's winners on a Wednesday we have
David Taylor David Taylor has done
pretty much every property investment
strategy since coming to the property
investors crash course only just under a
year ago killing it just secured a no
money down deal with a gross development
value of 1.4 million and I want to be
picking his brain he's gonna be telling
you everything so when we first met you
had been in poverty for all your life
yeah it's about 21 years in fact okay
well as in construction originally way
to me does application company left
school at 15 started their day after
school day after left school worked all
the way through and then ended up
becoming they're offered to draw up a
drop job in a drawing office in a block
in Blackpool took a half a pay cut
because they went from the being of
qualified fabricator to an office junior
again but then I progressed the way up
to become an instruction engineer and
then in 1990 became a partner in a
multi-discipline practice going on from
there and when we met you're very
experienced in property but you haven't
really been doing investment for
yourself you'd been more doing stuff for
other people right
yes student former clients yeah making
them millionaires for years
well I but handling doing it for
yourself and it's interesting because
when you were the crash course which was
was that last year now yes it was last
July it was it was actually me 50th
birthday presents myself yeah I said to
me partner Michelle that I want she
asked me where I want to be 50th
birthday I said well I've actually
bought on this Samuel ease crash course
and she said what's that so I had to
explain to her shoulders new videos and
then she went down to London real zaebis
hotel we stayed in there and then I've
signed off the DfE the first day and
then we've got talking on the knife said
you need to do the Academy cuz she seeks
you know was that what I would obviously
well in it probably would obviously
where I'm here now hopefully yeah and so
we did that and then well that's part of
the bargain we had because it was my
birthday
she bought to go to Paris to 24 hours
later so then we went straight to Paris
after the there's a crazy weekend yes
when was your actual did you actual
birth they fall under why you at the
crash course yes
oh no way
I used in the 50th birthday this so you
were on your 50th birthday you were
actually at the crash course being
accused of being miserable by now yes I
have I got in because we went straight
to the front row yeah I was sat there
cuz I cuz I was concentrating that much
listening I have family for arms folded
and obviously I just here with me is
quite serious but it seemed serious fast
let's see it yeah yeah that was it yeah
and obviously I was I was Constantine
that hard on what you were saying and
those and afterward you came up to us
and just said was what was your did you
find that boring or did you what was all
what was a problem yeah so you sat there
and you just it was you know it didn't
seem interested said no honestly I was
really interested as I was I was I was
concentrating that hard and what you're
saying
yeah that I just be come across as being
a bit you know it's funny though how
many people were there at that venue
remember that's about the most having
about 600 at least probably a thousand
yeah probably a thousand no it was
actually it was at the abyss yeah it
would have been yeah yeah
but anyway hundreds and hundreds but the
fact that I spotted you and I came over
to you and said how you doing and you
doing okay that's how sensitive I am to
my audience they yeah
little did I know it was your 50th
birthday and not only that but you'd
come and you told me just recently that
you wanted to do every single strategy
yes in property so you know join the
Academy what firstly how was the crash
course it's fantastic yeah it might it
totally changed everything because I
won't have been doing on now if haven't
gone on the crash course and I've
probably just thought about it and not
done nothing about it but yeah she
doesn't motivate you today with an
actual physical part I don't never told
you this
can I tell you why I wanted you to join
the Academy so bad oh god oh it's two
reasons reason number one because I knew
you were going to do really well and
you've been property for years and years
and years and I kind of wanted to take a
little bit of credit for your success
okay
reason number two because you literally
when we will speak at the crash course
you've got you a background of architect
and engineering and I thought you're so
knowledgeable when it comes to property
I knew that the Academy members would
love having you on the
cat on me so I thought you'd actually be
an asset to the Academy so it's kind of
very selfish of me really
yeah yeah it's worked out well for me in
the end as well cuz they're well I enjoy
passing my knowledge on to everybody I
mean you have you've passed it in fact
I've learnt things from you about
property ya know so and I think that's
the thing with the Academy it's more
than just a training program yes you get
loads of different training programs but
also it's a community you joint-venture
new network and i know you've done a lot
of joint venturing a lot of networking
and and done all kinds of deals taught
me through some of you deals yeah well
the actual first deal I I had stopped
from joining and the Academy I'm doing
the crash course yeah I was looking to
source a piece of land on I haven't
become compliant as a deal source at
that point in time so I approached
another a caddy remember which is James
Armstrong to try and sell his name
always comes oh yeah and I've been
together with Anthony of those trying to
find an investor for us yeah that would
have been a fee of 26,000 pounds so I
was quite happy to take the land
sourcing fee we did we did find an
investor but for four reasons they
decided not to continue so I was
speaking to the the the land agent he
was actually selling on the land
unbeknown to me at the time he had
actually bought in the land himself yeah
and he just said do you think we could
do you think we could build out the
houses and I said certainly I've been
doing this for years for all the clients
so I said right okay we looked it found
an investor then so we got an investor
to port with the funds and then we
talked about getting a builder on board
to do as a joint venture yeah so I spoke
to one of me somebody I know is a local
builders a young lad and we decided to
do a joint venture construction company
to build out the houses that the houses
is 3d test houses you know they're gdv
of 1.4 million and it says a return on
investment of about 35% which is about
450,000 caresse complete and it's to to
start in the next couple of weeks so
you've completed on that yeah it's cool
it's plodding come it's got planning
full planning approval planning
discharged
contrast drawn and drafted and ready to
start hitting the ground next couple of
weeks and you're gonna make just under
half a million pounds as a joint venture
yeah question how much money did you put
into that deal it was a non money down
deal for myself
so they do exist it's just me this just
normal are penny not even at so you
didn't put a penny into the deal what do
you think when people say you can't do
no money down Dale's about then alright
this did they do happen they can't
happen it might be I'll see it's
normally down from it for me but there
is someone in office or specialist but
he's making the biggest profit yeah so
that's that's divine but for me I'm
happy I've got not put it in not
invested a penny of the old money of
what buy time into it but again he times
quite free yeah a relatively so but
again so it's been a very good deal for
us and you've done that but you've also
done a series of other deals which we
can talk about you've done went around
see if that options you've done by
refurbished refinance you go by two
let's you've absolutely been smashing it
for these last how many months have been
on the Academy I officially did me
launchpad in November yeah
so it's eight months yeah I did the
crash course in July launch pattern of
them so similar kind of time to Darren
and Ella yes I've met Darren our on the
ice on the launch pad
who are on when is Wednesday a couple of
weeks ago yes in fact they were the ones
that made you want to come up with yes I
saw the poster afterwards after they had
the phone call from yourself
I saw the post where Darren and said
it's about time you had itself on it and
I yeah I don't know run realized he put
that up in an hour and then tell him a
few more people commented because you
weren't easy to get on this show where I
don't miss it I did not want to come on
it originally I've said no before we
just peel because it was I didn't think
I was ready yeah for it but obviously
and people have explained to me that
obviously that deal is quite a big deal
to me
it's a massive deal and not only that
we've done loads of other deals yes so
we can always do a part 2 when it's
Wednesday wants you're a multi
multi-millionaire I'd definitely be on
it yeah for sure
talk to me about some of the other deals
though because you you can't when you
came on the account
yeah you weren't really aware of things
like serviced accommodation on these
different strategies and you've managed
to combine them really well tell me
about the deal that you bought which
you've done as a buyer refurbished
refinance / serviced accommodation / Lee
you've just talked to me about that deal
brilliant again
that was actually I used a deal sorcerer
as well yeah to find that one who was
the deal salsa it was John and Becky
okay Johnny Becky yeah yeah right
they've also been on Windows where my
day yeah the I've got talking silk was a
little black Paul and they just said I
found his property is it it's a cracking
deal I said yeah lots of the figures did
me on due diligence as well as theirs
and it was fantastic
yeah so if it's Trump straight forward
back to let that's what I was intending
to do it would have been us every buy
new favorite or fire dozen rent and they
would have written grossed about two
three hundred pounds a month
yeah or a straight flip it would have
been a twenty two thousand pounds profit
yeah sorry it worked on that ends and
then I went on the rental Revolution
yeah and then we talked about essays on
that and then I thought oh where it is
situated a lot Paul that would make a
cracking essay so that an redid redid
the figures on it and it was it was a no
brainer it turned out to be well over
fifteen hundred pound a month profit
profit so hold on a minute you bought
the house how much you pay for it you
paid fifty one thousand for it okay and
how much you spent doing you up it's ten
thousand pounds so you invested in total
61 grand yeah and how did you find
certain use your own cash to use
bridging where was intended to reuse
bridge in what it calls for the short
timescale area and we used our own cash
fine
it also made the deal a bit more sweeter
because it's not paying the preaching
fees so you put 61 grand in 51 grand you
bought it and you spent 10 grand doing
it up yeah
what did the refinance valuation come
back at it's coming back over 83,000 I
think for edible yeah so we soon as it
finished well we're getting remortgaged
on a buyer to let yeah that's that's
gonna be about hundred and forty nine
pounds a month and then the because we
own it we've known rent to pay so it
works even better for an essay yeah so
you expected to make about 1500
and among profit on that yeah yeah
that's just absolutely insane yeah
that's based on a seventy-five percent
occupancy as well which is realistic
yeah a black point and you know that it
will work as an essay because you've got
a rent to a same black pool yeah yeah
yeah
it's a joint venture again it's just
outside block points a place called a
living Saint Anne's okay I could just
slap more affluent area so in that
property we can collect we can get it
rented out for 200 to 250 pounds a night
it's it's quite own private gated
entrance it's got two private parking
spaces it's a two bedroom villa
apartment mmm and you commander
helicoptering me in the front lawn
oh goodness so it's it's right on the
seafront in live in st. Anne's so
fantastic
you don't them don't come very often so
and that's all live now it'd be alive in
about three or four weeks okay because
because we can't open it yet is that
because of Corona Corona yeah so when
that goes live what kind of cash flow
expected to make from that one went to
rent property because it's a joint
venture we it's met about a thousand
pounds each net but I don't think we'll
end up make him more but if we work on
the conservative at least a thousand
because it should grossed about three
four what why would you mess around
doing a rent to rent when you make you
know you've got a one point four million
gross development value what's your
strategy what's going on here I want to
do all strategies when I first like it
when I first on the academy bought it
that's gives cash flow now the the the
development one will be cash flow well
beard yeah you'll make a lot of money
down a lot on the line yeah for now it
helps on the cash flow where and also it
makes money it'd be silly not to do it
do it any any of the strategies that
don't make money yeah I got the
telephone call John to be a joint
venture on it and lots of numbers again
it was it was a straightforward yes you
know cuz well I spoke to Michelle Morano
just say just say are we happy because
we have a I could property business
together
the we both phone so we just said yeah
the number stats up and that was it we
coming on and what's your motivation
behind making all this money in property
doing all these strategies
yeah when I first joined when I went for
the history of crash course and then
joined the Academy the the reasons
behind was to build a legacy for the
mainly for the children and also build
wealth for ourselves yeah and legacy
that the we can build our own portfolio
up that they can share in so they can
all get some sort of profit from it in
future again if they want to be involved
in property that all can look and all
come on board a couple of them have
audience how they mention the Oliver's
doing property now with you yeah I live
has done some property with us now eat
he's doing some of the construction work
on one of the actual units
it was just mainly to show them that you
don't have to do the work yourself but
at least they've got to do it now if you
saw was stripping wallpaper things that
we're doing the basics stasis now with
damp course could you actually not the
plaster off it was an agent often
skipped we not talked last off the wall
we loaded it up but I was trying to
prove a point that perhaps if you were
searching for a property or looking for
other things well it's got to look good
to get your hands dirty because I got
nowadays with my father working from
construction and washing he can it gives
you the value of somebody else's work
money worth and also yeah once you know
how it's done
it doesn't mean you've then gonna do it
right yes it doesn't you don't you don't
have to do it at I we probably never do
it ever again um today extent yeah it
you times more vulnerable doing
something else when you've only got
limited time it's why I would always use
I want to be adverse using deal sorcerer
because whilst become founder own
sometimes you you'll be too busy doing
something else yeah for that month and
really you've got to carry on buying
properties so if the children can learn
to do deal sourcing which is what
they're looking at now then they can
find the properties but they can also
sell them on to already investors hmm so
we're looking to we're looking to gain
our investor list now that's the name
things became compliant in February yeah
port because of Corolla we've just
decided to concentrate on what we're
physically doing well though you've been
busier than ever there during this
lockdown hi of yeah yeah yeah I've never
stopped looking we're working for land
parcels then I've been looking for quite
a lot of land because you can't come
the physical viewings on the properties
mm-hmm but so we're looking over gain
uplift on plots of land say there was a
house what you could build in the back
garden or you could find another
property where it might have a driveway
where he could build a tourist property
we lost one well we was due to buy or
purchase one last week in auction we had
all the funds in place we asked the
auction house he was a non-modern
won an auction online the modern system
walked online but we asked could we put
an offering before and said no the day
of the auction came was sat there
getting ready to make our bids sold
prior to auction oh we was extremely mad
with fuming we were ranked up the
auction house says you told us we can't
make a pre pre bid said Arnall that came
from a different office so they said
well you know we so it was and that was
a deed an end of terrace is that for
ninety thousand it needed about thirty
thousand pounds doing spending on to to
do the property or but we could build
two tastes houses in the driveway next
to it which would have been one hundred
and forty five thousand each so that
would have been a massive deal ball
again you say you got it celebrate your
citizen and you disappointments you just
gotta hustle I can't remember that's the
one yeah yeah and we have done that
we've had a few things like that we will
we will we're looking at another auction
property there's a slight two problem it
actually ended up being the breaching
finance
we've been in the issue yeah because
we're gonna title split it and the the
one last title split' prior to the
bridge so we just ended up forgetting
about that property because we got some
we've also learned very quickly if
there's too many issues just caught the
next day there's always a nobody yeah
exactly
and get about that one yeah people get
so hung up that they get so emotionally
attached to the idea of doing a deal
they end up almost throwing their brains
out yeah and that's why I always say
it's about forming there's not feelings
yeah but I learned that very rapidly
that's it yeah spot on if the numbers if
there's too many problems and the
numbers don't work
come on to the next one what was the
feeling like when you refinanced your
first house and poured all your money
out of that buy-to-let as fantastic yeah
great we it it was quite a large twenty
of 17,000 so - and also no capital gains
tax because you've increased the
increased your debt so that's yeah
that's the part most most satisfying
exactly and we talked about this at the
crash course event about at the no
capital gains in tax when you refinance
yeah
so you pulled out all your money and
some yes how much extra currently it's
about six thousand ask you to be
refinanced again which we're not gonna
overlap regions just to keep you at 75
percent yeah so just going up and up
that one then
yes great okay and you've also you've
done a not gonna hate him Oh yet no but
what was the other deal as well that
you're working on got there's a three
plots of land yeah can't be negotiating
with the landlord it's put options on to
gain the planning uplift
on the demand we were looking to put
small to like industrial units on so
they can either they could have like a
b1 b2 and b8 which is we want you know
you've got office use you've got light
industrial and they got v8 storage use
but they are small the value of them is
less than one hundred thousand pounds
each unit or that means that a joiner a
builder or a small office can purchase
and we'll rent them off yeah they do
there are quite profitable series of
developments mmm support there was a
planning process so we always put an
option on face on the land and then
split some of the profit with the land
on it
rather than having to buy it in yeah and
take the risk I can see why caddy
members cute to pick your brain and I
want to get onto some of the fa Q's that
you get to add value to all the YouTube
Watchers of the training programs that
you've done you've done obviously
bye-bye refurbish refinance you've got
all the different strategies which one
was the biggest like aha no man for yeah
yeah straight the the rent event
revolution with the SI yeah how does
that one made a massive difference to
that one individual property they the
deal solid mastery which is which is a
different way
we've land agents and I've dealt with
property agents and things I but not to
these knots of the the straightforward
biota let's you can sell them um that
was amazed you could and I bought one
I'm a prime example of a purchase to buy
at Alette I paid a fee for it freed up
some wire time or it may its shall be it
is possible to do it on a small scale
and I've been used to the reason for joy
mean one of the reasons are well for
joining Academy is to learn all the
initial stuff that mist yeah because I
was doing large large property deals for
my clients but I missed about the HMO
was that chilly note said in it we
wouldn't necessarily be looking for
turnin her to bed into a for bed yeah we
were buying a a for bed set into six or
eight bed yeah the things like that so
that that was opened our eyes opened
like an option I'm one of the properties
now which is going through at the moment
he's you just got delayed because of CO
vid evaluation and that's a in Burnley
that one's a to bed with to reception
rooms I can make it a for bed H well and
it's an HR over HMO area yeah but once
that completes and I love a look at that
one but it still works as a matter let
because I also teach about outs you've
got to have a number of outs yeah the
more you have the better it is so that
one works as a straight fall back to
levels as an HMO he'll probably
quadruple the revenue yeah so that's
great and you've made so many friends on
the Academy yes
yeah it's been fantastic I mean the the
Academy I know so is a family of people
everybody's got the same interest they
all wants to do well they wanted to get
well in property everybody helps each
other that you can network you did you
can basically people bring each other
anytime of the day there's also support
from that yourself
Russell Alastair Ricky Antony I've
always I've never had a problem there
being able to message anybody and other
response its and also I still ask
questions I don't know if he finishes
but I'm happy to help people as well so
if it's something that's there
I can help I will always offer to help
her I did say at the beginning I would
always join my property journey I wanted
to help as many people become
financially free as well as myself yeah
if I can open mean any little way award
in a knowledge of games I would do so
that's great and that's part of the
vision of our company yeah which is why
I like it I spoke to you that first time
after crash caucus yeah I kind of got
got the other standing what you want to
do when yeah and once you finish fall in
your arms and frowning at me yes but you
know what though your reason for doing
what you're doing for your kids I think
it's really amazing because you talked
about potentially as well setting all
the properties up in a trust
yeah which goes on to your kids to your
grandkids and great-grandkids perpetual
trust perpetual trust that's what that
was the intention so they could never
sell the properties they could sell them
if there's an emergency
yeah but the console a certain
percentage it spoke to solicitors and
that they can be done and hopefully
that's will have enough properties
eventually to be able to do that and it
be a passive income if they need to draw
off it if if not what a great way to
leave a legacy there yeah to be the
first person in potentially a whole
family tree of history to leave an asset
a portfolio that's protected thusly
giving a passive income that's
incredible
what do you what are your parents doing
in construction well me he does passed
away but me you doubt had a fabrication
company and I worked for him for a day
before the day after I left school at 15
ya know and I a web for him became a
fully qualified fabricator engineer
welder and then left there to go to work
for a drawing office in Blackpool and
then work my way up there did 12 years
at Maskull because I kind of left school
with very little qualifications I was
gonna be a fabricator so we didn't
really need any qualifications over then
you know what to work with my hands yeah
I wasn't I wasn't the most academic of
students but I would say but I had to go
back and did be a level maths and did I
feel suit then and that's cool to then
become an engineer and then we've
progressed into a multidisciplinary
practice now we've got yeah five staff
that work for us
we do from simple porch extensions to
football stadiums we don't allow so
incredible and you've also I believe I'm
right in saying this you've set up a new
construction company just as a result of
the workload that you would get him from
it from one of your big deals that
you've got off the academy and all the
network that you've got yeah is that
right yeah talk about that have him
obviously the three houses were was due
to build yeah for ourselves we decided
with the Builder to set of a joint
venture company to do that one and build
that one out and then we've been a we've
actually doing for another Academy
member on an investor a thirteen bed HMO
in burden Lee and then we're good doing
a public conversion doing the
construction work for that we've also
got some small industrial units though
they were going to build out for
ourselves but it's it's turned into
about 1.8 million pounds worth of work
in less than eight months but again
because we because we know what they
need yeah on the HMOs becomes help them
out and get the plans drawn or modified
and keep the bill costs down how many
times didn't you you'll have earned back
your Academy fee multiples lots of all
multiples that we we have the first deal
would have it's about twofold
yeah even if it's all to land off never
mind constructing it and the the Reds do
about the same blackpool more than
covers covers it's a more than happy but
they does anything I think sometimes
people people that think that the
training is expensive it's probably not
for them because if you're gonna do the
business anyway if you're gonna do deals
and you're gonna it kind of makes sense
for the network and for the training you
negate all I think it kind of makes
sense to pay for it yeah I mean you were
at that time I signed up for the Academy
meet Michelle we would set up the DfE
first I remember persuading Michelle
Michelle and so you offered her would
such a good deal that she came on there
yeah the DfE
and but that the following day she said
to me you've got to go and do it
you should she knows well I will succeed
in it and obviously she backed me open
quietly if Michelle wasn't backing me up
I don't think I'd have being where we
are today it's like it's made a massive
difference if you have a partner that's
interested in it and the support your
way through there's been no negativity
on regarding me doing it and carrying on
and yeah I did have a heart attack
paying the fee I'm not saying that said
if there's a lot of money or yeah it's
got it you did actually say to me he
said if it doesn't hurt yeah you're not
gonna put the effort in yeah and he and
I'm one of these person that probably if
it was only a couple of grand you want
to put the effort in mmm and it wouldn't
waste for me but it's been value in the
end you know the value you get from it
I've got from anyway as being more than
adequate for me I mean it's been
fantastic
and we've had a lot of value from you
being members and Michelle is incredible
we've just had a barbecue before fill me
with yourself and Michelle some of the
questions that the Academy members ask
you because I know they all pick your
brain you pick their brain they ask you
about permitted development what what
what is permitted development or
permissive elements is it's effectively
it's the local variety have certain
aspects of a build allow you to do
without a she applying for planning
permission you can build small
extensions at the back single-story
extensions up to three metres high and a
certain distance away from the building
which you don't need permission for you
can convert you can do permitted
development which is probably more
prevalent now for a lot of people on the
academy where they've starting to
progress the next level where they're
going from residue going for commercial
to residential yeah so if you get a
commercial office you can convert into
residential without client permission so
I've been asked lots of questions is he
just straightforward it is it's just
straightforward you can get any office
block and turn it into residential yeah
again there's also some regarding
commercial to residential in a main
shopping area you you can get permission
to build the flats of off as but still
cause you have to keep the retail right
now
with what's going on with the lockdown
and the pandemic I think commercial to
residential is a very attractive
strategy because there's a lot of
offices and empty warehouses and units
which are selling quite cheaper than
don't know if you've seen that
yes well yeah and they as a high street
starts to come back online they'll be
even more because of some of the smaller
shops smaller premises won't be
reopening yeah a lot of business have
gone online you can still keep what will
happen I think will happen is deal
though because you can get committee
development to release part of the
ground floor area into residential
little you you will only have a small
shop front and then the rest will be
residential now in this in it the town
centers would be a lot more of it
happening again
the the younger generation now I want to
live in towns yeah so it's becoming more
prevalent to the back end have more
flats apartments in city centers which
is which is what's happening in
Manchester I've been working on a lot of
apartment blocks in Manchester so you
can really push the value up by turning
a commercial property into a residential
inner in a center yes what about land
you talking a lot about land you do a
lot of land a lot of a cutting them is
asking you I think the biggest question
that you say comes up is how do you
value a piece of land here yeah yeah
it's affected a big enough to know quite
a few question about land appraisal yeah
so it's finding a plot of land finding
out what the land value should be at or
how much you should be paying for the
land what the uplift value will be if
you get them if you get Planning
Commission on that land and it
effectively
I've sat with a couple of them and gone
through the various stages of looking
for the local plan assessing the local
plan to see what type of permitted
development would be there or what type
of development that would allow sort of
time to screen belt which you can't do
yeah also it's the uplifting the value
of the land you can find what's called
infill plots which a small plot of open
land in between it must fetch a
residential area which is you can build
a developments on there
almost guarantee planned mission they
call it mother if there's an infield
plot so yeah you're not you're not
building him a Greenbelt area
there's also I've been asked to look at
to how you value the land mainly is is
so I'll be going through the process
that with a couple of them and
explaining you know it is this various
aspects to value the London that's very
well but document you need to read it
yeah it's not stuff it's not just
straightforward it's not as easy to
going on mouth price stuff no but it is
very simple but it's a lot of research
and learn a lot of comparables yeah but
also I sometimes I just recommend you
getting back up with a wick surveyor
which but but before you make the offer
and pay for a Rick's of a you need to
know the basics yeah sure so I think one
of the really interesting things that I
see you posting on the Academy grow on
the forum is about buying properties
where you don't need to pay stamp duty
yeah and also properties that might be a
mortgageable that you can make them more
visible and then refinance them and you
you gave the definition of what makes a
property exempt from stamp duty and to
be honest I was like I never knew that
was the exact reason cuz I know if a
property is habitable you don't need to
post mgj but what does inhabitable mean
because you shared this with me it was
very useful yeah most people think it's
more than what it actually really is it
actually the term on that uninhabitable
for mortgage purposes is the main one is
no running hot water or no central
heating which that mr. Naumann in hot
water means if the boiler does not work
and cannot be easily repaired which in
some instance it has to be have a brand
new we probably installed it's not more
visible at that point so becomes
uninhabitable
so that's brilliant that so you get
stuff so we just we just find houses
we've a boiler that needs replacing
which might cost 1,000 or 2,000 pounds
yeah and there's something you don't
post haven't you - yeah you have to go
through your solicitor and the sister
has to make it has to log that with the
HMRC yeah it is a straightforward
process
the other one is it's got severe dump
another reason from
being and habitable the electrics what
the the main one is actually the is
simplex that one is that when there's no
hot water because if you can't have
heated there's no there's nowhere to
wash but you don't need all of these
problems you just need one of them right
yes so that's fantastic
yeah so what are your plans over the
next sort of where you've been on the
Academy for eight months
why do you plans for the next eight
months we're carrying on to actually but
build up up our own property portfolio
so we've been Latin HM oh yeah that's
one of the things we humpin that's one
of the very few strategies you've not
done out of all you've raised finance
joint venture options service
accommodation yeah land but not hm I
know but that's what we want to do yes
shall we that was where I should start
looking for yes because we know that
that's the best way to get okay it
covers your voids because if you have
one mom you might only have one or two
people out of the property at one time
it's the best strategy yeah for the
small Terrace properties although there
were four or five bedrooms I would like
to do a large HMO for again that I think
that's quite a way off yet but and also
carry otters we are just building up our
portfolio no I do a few more essays I
think I said well you're making a lot of
money off essays at the moment so that's
a good one so that'd be another one than
just just carrying on really you started
on the deal selling master class online
version as well yes
how's that going it's going through hey
Ashley yeah I really want to do the live
course but again I found out that you
can with the online version you can keep
going back yeah and we watching it yeah
and I have a pretty bad memory sometimes
the people in a normally very well will
say so it's ideal for me to keep going
watching it yeah and and then I can do
me notes and things like that and
sometimes you do miss that key bit of
information because you're trying to
concentrate on write down everything
else when you bought again it together
the together with that with the
obviously the the live version is it's a
strange version online is good and it's
good for going backwards but the live
version
yeah you can't just hide you've got to
do it yeah there's a group of you there
you all help at each other he sitting on
your own he's okay and doing it yeah the
actual live version is it yeah and we
love having you the events you know
honestly because I don't think you can
beat the physical live training program
the online stuff's going really well
it's helping you cutting them there's
what would you say to somebody who was
considering doing the property investors
crash course what would your advice be
you've got to do it that's it simple as
that
it it's you've got to experience it to
understand and don't be scared it it you
get taught it's sholden off to be able
to actually make a deal yeah and and
carry on and then you obviously there's
other strategies and things you need to
learn and probably do better on but it's
it changed well like I said I won't be
Satya now if I have lots of crash course
and I think I posted I think it always
starts at the crash course I think that
was mother it all started the crash
course yeah yeah and I'm definitely
support that it does because it's a
mindset thing as well you you because
it's a you are physically doing
everything they're moving in the agency
booking the viewings you you haven't
gone home and sat on when done nothing
you've actually done it so you you've
done it there and you you going out in
the next day or the week after which is
quite a few of their cutting members
who've always been well the other ones
I've spoken to evolved on the crash
course and the and the the one where
they are I found I've done the class
course yeah yeah well I'm really
impressed with what you've done
thank you for the value brought onto the
Academy thanks for coming on winners
Wednesday no this isn't going to be the
first time you're gonna be on YouTube
there's going to be a part 2 coming very
soon and yeah thanks so much for calling
show we're sure the best in the future
thanks Sam
guys I hope you enjoyed that David one
awesome humble guy you want to meet
people like David you want to learn what
David learned you want to become
financially free first you need to
subscribe to the channel right here
secondly you need to watch more videos
you can watch more videos right here but
you know what you want to be mentored
you want to get the training you can do
that in Samuel 365 I'll leave a link in
the description
Samuel uses Viacom Network be trained us
real soon thanks for watching